trois semaines de couvre-feu nocturne
voilà ce qui attend et martinique et à
compter de ce vendredi
les dépassements sont interdits entre
22h et 5h du matin sauf motif
professionnel médical ou impérieux une
décision annoncée par le préfet ce mardi
afin de limiter la multiplication des
rassemblements à l'origine de la hausse
des contaminations
nous avons constaté une augmentation des
rassemblements non autorisés sur les
plages sur la voie publique une
augmentation des infractions dans les
établissements accueillant du public en
soirée une difficulté de distanciation
et de port du masque et le non respect
des horaires de fermeture qui ont été
sanctionnés par 30 mise en demeure et
cinq fermetures territoire jusque là
relativement épargné par la crise
sanitaire lamarti connaît une flambée
épidémique depuis fin février
avec 80% d'hélico vie déjà occupé et un
taux d'incidence en augmentation les
martiniquais doivent faire face à la
forte présence du variant anglais ce
dernier représenterait 50 à 60 % des 400
cas recensés la semaine dernière d'après
le responsable de santé publique france
en martinique
face à cette situation la campagne de
vaccination devrait être prochainement
renforcée
objectif du préfet vacciner 3000
personnes par jour